this week on genv you know I could take
my glove off and make
you I won't cuz I'm all about consent
why you always
ly oh my
God throw consent out the windows ladies
and super jents we have a new villain on
the Block you're a monster and she'll
make you forget that she even is one in
this brand new episode of genv we'll
find out if Kate is Dean shed's daughter
the real purpose of the woods a surprise
connection between Victoria Newman and
Marie and most most importantly what
happened to rufus's dick now you'll want
to stick around till the end of the
video as I go over the trailers and new
theories on what's going on at gulkan
youu so relax with a VOD burger and make
sure to like And subscribe because holy
a lot is happening imagine waking
up and having this unexplained bodily
fluid on your face that's exactly what
happens to Andre who wakes up besides
Kate having no recollection of how we
got here it makes me really miss my
college days I love how we can see a v
burger fries and empty turbo Rush cans
on the ground the set designers really
go above and beyond in the show Andre
and Kate have found themselves at
Dusty's house a 28-year-old who looks
like he's 14 yeah I still got a dick
like a hairless caterpillar we aren't
sure if he's a student at gulkan or just
runs this frat house nor do we know if
he has a power but stick around for my
trailer section because I think I know
what he can do Kate also says she
doesn't remember anything that happened
but to that I say that was a lie
upstairs we have Maverick Marie's in
visible ra being led by Sloan the alpaca
and please no King shaming we see a fire
breathing soup and a mermaid soup before
stumbling upon a truly horrific scene
now one of you has to tell me what's
going on here in the credits these two
are simply build as a naked man and
blist out woman our naked man has some
sort of vibrating power which we can see
on his hand this must make him very
popular with the ladies I'll have what
she's having especially this woman who
has a hole on her back don't tell Tech
knite which secretes well I think you
you can guess surprisingly that isn't
the most shocking thing Andre and Kate
see as they stumble upon Jordan and
Marie in bed together we saw them
together at the end of episode 4 and
neither of them know how they got there
in fact it seems Emma Jordan Marie Andre
and Kate have no recollection of what
happened after taking down Sam I love
how Dusty's room is adorned with a
citizen Starlight poster along with
images of homelander queen mave and a
train citizen Starlight was a reality
show from VA Studios that followed
Starlight Emma is chilling in a pool in
her giant form using the pool tarp as a
blanket last episode it was revealed
that in addition to getting small she
can get really big and as we'll see in
these Tik toks she was chugging straight
out of a keg she's known ever since an
incident at Buster beavers that she can
get big this isn't the only incident to
ever take place at a buster Beaver an
even more notorious one occurred with
black noir who has since been haunted by
images of Buster in his Forest Pals
Emma's mom made her swear never to turn
big again and this theme of not being
accepted Ed for who you are is echoed by
Jordan when she tells the story of her
first girlfriend and only wanting to be
in her boy form Emma and Jordan need to
be loved and accepted for who they are
and not who others want them to be we'll
see Emma kind of embrace her big form as
she gets noticed by other students and
eventually cracks the top 100 rankings
at number 88 a nice dawn of the seven
Starlight cutout here and collectible
cup both Emma and Marie have no idea how
they got here which is made even more
apparent when Sam arrives they don't
remember at all in fact they don't seem
to recall anything to do with Sam or the
woods now Sam found them because he
smelled Emma's Thro up and I do not want
to see how much that was considering how
big she was he has a dire warning for
them gulkan is dangerous and is
responsible for making them forget bless
Sam's schizophrenic heart since he tells
Emma that he'll find a way to make her
remember to remember that she is a hero
Emma had kind of given up trying to be a
hero going into gulkan for its
Performing Arts but deep down she wants
to be known as a hero she wants to prove
to others she can do it perhaps this is
why she was so insistent on helping
Andre and his Dangerous Mission to help
Sam I love how every episode we learn a
little more about the extent of Our
Hero's Powers Marie can sense other
people's blood even under their
fingernails and can predict when
someone's going to have their period
love the translucent vodka Banner in the
background which we'll see Jordan
drinking some later on but when the gang
gets together they realize they have a
serious problem on their hands all of
them are losing memories memories
involving s are specifically targeted
like Andre not remembering why he missed
his interview with Haley Miller the one
we saw in episode 2 at that time he was
breaking into Brink's office and finding
out all about the woods their whole
altercation with Sam last night has also
been wiped but thank God Marie still
remembers exploding rufus's dick how was
this dude's member blown off and the
next day he's at a frat party I think I
have an answer to that but we have to
wait until Kate's big reveal Dr cardosa
wants to quit after almost losing his
family to a runaway patient but Dean
Shetty won't let him go that easy after
all where's he going to get a job
cutting up soups she assures him that
everything's been handled and to ease
his mind she offers him almost anything
he wants Marie as a test subject
claiming her abilities are the rarest
he's ever seen it's here we find out
what the woods is all about the goal is
to create a virus that can control soups
and cardosa says he's close to
perfecting it we know that some viruses
can spread via blood so that may be one
of the reasons he's interested in Marie
but shett says that Marie is off limits
that she has a quote benefactor is
Shetty lying or is there a mysterious
person needing Marie around and how if
at all does Murray's sister fit into any
of this I think I know who this
benefactor is but stick around till the
end of the video Murray has no
recollection of why she was talking to
Rufus in the first place we however know
she went to him in the hopes he'd use
his powers to locate Emma but Kate has a
startling accusation that in first year
he used his powers to her of course this
enraged es the group especially Andre
who's been very close with Kate as of
late if they can get to him perhaps they
can also figure out why he's been wiping
their memories Jordan and Marie discuss
the awkward situation of waking up naked
next to each other and not remembering a
thing both of them are playing it cool
unsure if the other actually likes them
or not later Marie will talk to Emma
about her feelings towards Jordan and
Jordan will talk to Maverick about their
feelings towards Marie at Classic does
my crush actually like me scenario over
the past few episodes Marie's distrust
of shett has grown so when she sees her
with Rufus it only increases her
speculation something rotten is going on
Jordan and Marie run after him only to
find themselves tricked by Benny a shape
shifter who was given 20 bucks to knock
them off rufus's scent you'll even
notice Benny's version of Rufus wears a
different shirt than the real Rufus
Andre waits for Rufus in his dorm room
and we see him using his power to shut
the metal door and windows I've long
suspected that the gulan dorms can be
transformed into a sort of prison and
this only confirms it Rufus says he
never never touched Marie in fact it was
Marie who attacked him when he says this
I think he's actually referring to being
chased by her and not the explosion what
if that whole dick Fiasco was a memory
implanted into Marie by Kate to
corroborate her allegation to make Rufus
look like the bad guy I mean the
alternative is that he has some sort of
magical dick Rejuvenation ability which
if he does Rufus please DM me Rufus also
recalls being attacked by Kate a
reference to episode two where every
hour he'd have to swing a baseball bat
into his dick and yell J
anii one thing I do want to know about
Kate's power is how long her pushes work
like is Rufus still swinging a bat into
his dick every hour or does it kind of
wear off Andre threatens Rufus but wakes
up at everyone's favorite restaurant
vurger so it looks like Rufus can
telepathically use his power as long as
according to him he's close to the other
person while cleaning up her room Emma
finds the Stardust sweater we saw her
wearing last episode Sam had mentioned
Stardust earlier in the day and he seems
to be their only connection into finding
out what's really going on at gulan it's
this sweater that will later lead Emma
back to the theater and the Revelation
that it was Kate who was behind to
wiping all their memories Sam knows all
about Kate's power having fallen victim
to it years ago at Sage Grove she was
even using it on Golden Boy so that he'd
forget he has a brother meanwhile Sam
has to fend off a group of soldiers
hellbent on taking him back we saw last
episode how he sometimes manifests
people as puppets likely as a way to
reduce the trauma from what he's about
to do do somehow ripping apart a
puppet's head feels a little less
violent than the real thing back at
gulan Emma notices Marie is scratching
her neck like Tyrone bams and it's not
nice to pay actors and crack day using
her sanguine skills she's able to
identify a clot and burst it to reveal a
Tracker we'll find that Jordan has one
too does every Gooden student have one
or just a select few Murray barges into
Andre's room to find Kate there and for
a brief moment we can see that she was
watching a Starlight moisturizer
commercial no out a part of the Vitality
line but as Marie goes off explaining
how this whole thing is bigger than
Rufus and that Dean shett is a part of
it Kate wipes her memory Kate has been
secretly working with Dean chett in her
mind her actions were a necessary evil
to protect the ones she loves from harm
now I don't know about you but I got
total motherdaughter Vibes here in
episode three we learned that Kate was
EST strange from her parents they
wouldn't even touch her after they found
out about her power could Chetty have
adopted her or at least become a
mother-like figure in that same episode
Shetty tells Marie that she used to have
a daughter you have a
daughter I did maybe Kate lost her
parents and Shetty lost her daughter and
the two have been kind of using each
other to fill those respective rules
shett also refers to Kate as sweetheart
and implies that they've been doing
these wipes for a long time their nails
are both done the same way and their
conversation seems to take place at
ched's home not at her office which
gives it a more personal tone all these
things combined give me the suspicion
there is some form of motherdaughter
connection here Past posters for payback
race to death and clueless perhaps a nod
to our characters having no clue what's
going on Emma learns about Kate's wiping
from Sam meanwhile Kate is snuggled up
next to Andre watching mesmerizer this
is an older show starring child soup
actor Mesmer who has telepathic Powers
we saw the adult version of him in the
boy season 1 played by Haley Joel Osman
Billy butcher smashed his face in after
it was found out he betrayed the boys to
homelander Andre confides in Kate that
he wants out of Gul that the two of them
should leave she wants this too but can
we really believe her meanwhile Murray
and Jordan confront Rufus who once again
states he never touched any of them and
the reason he was seen with Dean Shetty
is that he works in the Dean's office
even though Dusty is here high off 2cb a
psychedelic he vouches for Rufus
providing him with an alibi Rufus
couldn't have been the one to wipe Marie
at that moment Marie receives a call
from Emma confirming it wasn't Rufus but
none other than Kate but before we can
get to the bottom of it Andre storms in
pin Hing Rufus against the wall with a
pair of garden shears he's about to get
some good oldfashioned Justice until
Kate Stomps him and reveals the truth it
looks like Kate has the ability to give
people their Memories Back as seen with
this brief Montage of memories wiped
from Andre if Andre can get his Memories
Back it looks like the others will get
theirs too this is a tremendous betrayal
of the highest order for Andre and he
calls Kate a monster the title of this
episode is welcome to the monster Club
just how Kate will recover from this is
unknown she'll be Persona n grada for a
while but with the gang getting their
Memories Back it looks like Dean
shetty's hold on keeping the woods a
secret is about to come undone Now we
move on to our trailer sleuthing section
where we take a look at the season's
trailers to see what might happen next
check out Dusty Jordan Marie and Andre
this has to be sometime close to the
events of this episode since they're
wearing the same clothes as when they
confronted Rufus this might be a stretch
but could this wooded area be near where
Dean Shetty confronted Tech knite a
place she said there were no cameras
check out these Woods prisoners in
agonizing pain this looks to be Dr
cardo's reflection and I bet he's
testing out a new version of his virus
we'll see this diseased prisoner who
seems to be afflicted with whatever
cardosa gave him Kate here awakens from
some sort of sleep or dream remember
that she often collapses when overusing
her power and we can see her bloodshot
eyes a side effect when she pushes too
much as Kate goes to touch Marie she
mysteriously vanishes this teleportation
thing could be Dusty's power all of them
seem to jump in this shot except for
Dusty here's Sam partying at the gulan
dorm my best guess is that he was taken
here by Emma to hide but get swept up
with making friends and partying
remember this guy has never had any
friends he's never experienced any
childhood whatsoever looks like Rufus
makes it out in one piece hope he's
listening to the latest Starlight
[Music]
Banger here are some students struggling
to make it out of the dorms before these
giant metal doors Clos in this episode
we saw how the dorms operate almost like
a prison so something has definitely
gone down will Golden Boy be back I
don't think we've seen him in this white
shirt suggesting we'll get more Golden
Boy flashbacks unless we're dealing with
a clone this appears to be an escaped
Woods prisoner judging by the gray
sweatpants and sweater she has laser
beams coming out of her eyes but I'm not
sure if this is the same woman we'll see
fighting Jordan who also has this power
Sam and Emma make out in front of a
polarity crane game implying that she
gets her Memories Back well even get
another Emma puppet sighting in the
coming episodes it looks like there will
even be a big debate on campus over soup
rights here are some protesters and
we'll see a conversation between
Victoria Newman and what might be
Cameron Coleman from vot news some of
the signs read stop Su Pate Heroes
United soups keep you safe and
Newman the red band trailer will have us
believe that Victoria has a one-on-one
conversation with Marie in which she
says this is your shot at real power is
Victoria Newman Marie's mysterious
benefactor they have a lot of in common
both Victoria and Marie killed their own
parents both of them attended Red River
and Victoria would be able to access
files on Marie and perhaps Marie's
powers can help Victoria in her campaign
but now I turn it over to you what do
you think will happen in the weeks ahead
I want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching please be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
you're a
monster